nous ne sommes pas surpris de la
décision de la justice nous attendions à
cette décision
donc nous avons été condamnés à libérer
les accès de la poste vous avez vu là le
nôtre piquet de grève n'est pas devant
l'entrée du centre de tri de dillon donc
nous formons un tout sur les différents
sites de la pose de la martinique
si nous avons des drapeaux qui sont
encore sur ses sites donc ces drapeaux
seront retirés
il n'y aura pas de présence de militants
ou d'éléments syndicaux devant les sites
de la martinique
il faut savoir que la pause par contre
été débouté sur l'article 700 donc c'est
à dire les 10000 euros qu'il demandait
voilà donc ça c'est une satisfaction
pour nous mais la mobilisation en fait
j'ai envie de dire commence aujourd'hui
le bras de fer commence à partir
d'aujourd'hui parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
aurons la démence à partir d'aujourd'hui
nous faisons la démonstration à faire à
la poste leur montrer que même si les
sites de la poste sont accessibles sont
libérés les postiers sont toujours en
grève